how's it going bros my name is Barry Pam
and welcome to another gameplay on this
channel I know a lot of you guys have
been waiting for this no for real Ibanez
on their tail tow so this game came out
it's called Delta rune it's basically
undertale - I think I'm not sure
they released chapter 1 but it's not
just a chapter it's an actual full game
as far as I could I know it's two hours
or something long so I'm freaking pumped
I loved playing undertale I think a lot
of people enjoy it as well so let's just
jump into it I wanted to show this just
because when you install the game it
says survey program you accept
everything that will happen from now on
yes except I won't accept putting on
Start menu shortcut that was an actual
joke let's do this okay oh god what did
I say I was suggesting my window are we
ready
connected it's almost the same I guess
we are okay it's an idea okay this is
hippy excellent
where is Sanj come on truly excellent
now now what we may begin
I know the future everyone guys
oh Jesus
[Music]
first you must create a vessel okay
select the head that you prefer all
right we got this one
select the torso that you prefer wow
there's so many different options how
could I possibly pick one hmm hmm I
think I think I'll go and you guys go
with that one
select the legs oh wow there's so many
different options how could I possibly
pick one this is your body do you accept
it well does anyone truly accept their
body that was so deep
excellent you have created a wonderful
form why thank you that's the first time
anyone told me that now except when I go
to the bathroom let us shape its mind as
your own what it's its favorite food
[Music]
pain tastes good right your favorite
blood type
I think I'm be I'm not sure favorite
blood type what color does it like the
most sign is pretty interesting
please give it a gift a gift mine I'll
be a psychic pokémon how do you feel
about your creation it will not hear are
you sure I'm I'm hopeful have you
answered honestly yeah I think so you
acknowledge the possibility of pain and
seizure no understood name your vessel
well of course you know what's happening
you know which has to be the legend has
to return to not say the word Oh
[Music]
we called it Saturday's we and what
about the Creator your own name
oh well I guess I'll pick Felix just
because usually these games are really
matter so I wanted to play into that
Felix what are still in it excellent yes
thank you for not ripping into my name
truly excellent Felix thank you for your
time
you are welcome now let's get on with
the game your answers your wonderful
creation will now be disc damn it no one
can choose who they are in theirs what
are you kidding me your name is God
Chris it's cow Bob all right this is
Chris if you Chris if you do not wake up
we will be late for school
I will wait outside for you right so
this is under Taylor is it not I can't
all right let's look around
it's a beautiful dancing man I miss this
the style and everything so great the
drawers ones they empty except for I
thank God my school cross country shared
with a tear in it I thought it would be
something else
damn I got a lot of trophies it's a
computer desk their nanny box our
hundred filled with old books all right
let's just get moving damn I look good
the doors okay great
damn it feels great to be playing this
what that was a big glitchy or like a
mistake I'll let it slide it's okay
this has to be the like it's a TV
doesn't even seem plugged in anymore all
right go Oh Chris there you are we might
still be able to make it
press it is a beautiful day today is it
not
I hope it stays this way when Azrael
visit make way so it is undertale but I
wonder after the excitement of
University when he still enjoy coming
home to this little town
is it like a prequel or something oh my
god oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah okay
library P this is great oh my god the me
a sec I'm freaking hype man
that's cute just don't home in school
mom Jesus Christ and why don't you go to
the right and not down where we came so
does everyone have an okay we thought
you weren't coming today we're doing
group project this map so walk around
and find a partner of cake god this was
the worst finding a partner in school
there was a lien during class seven and
eight that I actually had a friend to
partner with we were always like okay
we'll go and it was the best but if you
don't have that it's the worst now
obviously I'm gonna partner with the
snake great no jack turn and daddy are
always partners for the ultimate akattak
doing he's rubbing it in he's rubbing it
and ever since I first Jim place every
toll of day and they ran out of hooves
for us so she used me instead that's our
origin story damn it that is a great
origin story what about this thing right
no I hardly know her why do you think I
dare one four knee right no well I Got
News for You Pere I already got a
partner scram
sheesh what about yo Chris show up
earlier next time I ended up having a
party with snowy huh
now he keeps turning to me and saying
howdy partner like a cowboy cheese what
about Jesus great hey ridi hit what
there
is that an egg it's a black-and-white
hard-boiled egg
sadly seems to seems like it already has
a partner why is this game doing me like
this
alright come on man ah Chris late again
se hmm you need a partner sorry I'm
already partnered with the second
smartest student also you're the
smartest the wait Chris now that I think
about it your unique skillset might help
a lot on this assignment not Jesus
Christ that's asylum Olli I actually
want to get an A Jesus hey Chris what's
up did you lose your pencil again here
come on candy cane on one or the one
with lights on huh you want to be
partners sorry
apparently already asked me but I could
ask myself is if we can make a group of
three I'll ask if you're sure okay Jen
okay I'll ask miss a piece is it okay if
we have a group of three please hey what
no I do not approve this a boy but Chris
doesn't have it
know what that is what what are you
saying she was just saying we're fine
being alone well can you please pick up
Oh God I see Suzy Emily uh no you're
fine we were just that to choosing
partners for the next group radically
Suzy you're the winner is oh great
fantastic at least I get a partner oh
man I always got to get partnered with a
weirdos in class but not I think about
it I was probably the winner great
geesh
now that everyone's here I'll write the
assignment is this just gonna stand
there um has anyone seen the chunk this
is the third time it's gone missing in
you all know I can't start class with
that Sam
oh that's too bad I guess we won't have
class how about this if no one speaks up
everybody gets in trouble yeah they'll
do it I just try to drink with the lid
on please hey there might be a box in
the supply closet mishap is why don't
you see and I good idea no way Suzy said
you came in like why don't you go get
him for me whatever and grace can you go
with her and make sure she actually gets
it and stays out of trouble
thanks creep see you later fan tastic
what about you then click click tap tap
don't die what do you say that
grace if I had arms I would take off
this cool hat in remembrance of you god
damn Chris crash don't listen to him
it's not amping it you'll probably
survive Suzy's beating us
you're just gonna fail when she doesn't
do any of your project it's like we
always say Chris you says you lose you
laugh you you sass you lose that's not
very reassuring yo Chris I'm sorry
if I just waited to be your partner you
wouldn't have to be hers she's probably
gonna pound you to pieces Chris and then
kick the butts of all those little
pieces what does egg have to say about
this
I love the humor in these games so silly
did he just eat the child oh god Chris
didn't see them hey you didn't see
anything just now did you you can't even
say I don't know I can't really I'm not
really Gary giving you any options do
you mean Chris oh god it's open okay
Hey okay don't let me tell you a secret
you like eating oh God quiet people piss
me off
you think just cuz you don't say
anything I can't tell exactly what
you're thinking it over I caught Suzy
eating all the Chuck this was her last
chance now she'll finally be expelled ha
ha come on Chris don't act shocked you
know it's true everyone's been waiting
for it everyone wants it so congrats
Chris you got me I'm done for just let
me say one little thing it seems like a
waste to get expelled just for having a
slag so Chris if I know you're gonna
pull the trigger why don't I just get
expelled for some real carnage Chris how
do you feel Oh God
about losing your face I feel strongly
against it strongly against it strongly
against that now Chris you've got a good
one it'd be ashamed to make a barrier
child all right let's get me something
good we'll get more chalk mostly back to
class and then Chris you'll do our
project how's that sound
don't bother answering if you haven't
gotten it by now
your choices don't matter hey I don't
like weight if you don't talk by the way
don't talk let's go freak Jesus Christ I
almost died out there oh god he's
looking at me what happens if I just
leave grace you just gotta skip school
what am I supposed to snitch on you
that'd be rich huh Matt I wouldn't get
back here Chris if you skip school your
mom have a heart attack no Chris if you
okay all right all right fine I won't
get my mom a heart attack
God can you walk any slower or what now
I get it
and I used to walking around with
without someone holding your hand come
on freak jeez she's shrewish well here's
the closet we were just starting to have
fun that's a very ominous closet I must
say oh hey yeah Chris is it me or is it
really dark in there what's the holdup
Chris are you gonna go in or what fine
if you're gonna be a wimp then I'll
we'll go we'll both go in at the same
time seems fair
[Music]
say why are you so scared there's
nothing in here but old papers let's try
to find a light switch Chris if you
leave me here I'll okay all right okay
okay I'm here okay what's up
that's weird I can't find a switch gets
us further in oh god no God God God kind
of big for a closet huh you think would
have reached in by now
[Music]
hey Chris I think this closet that's
broken there under any walls well we
worked hard enough if Alfie wants to
talk so bad she can get hers out let's
play read that it guys uh Shh hey this
is a party that is a nervous
laughs ah that's okay
[Music]
that's dumb we're falling down
it's all happening again are we gonna
meet some monsters damn I look not an
Armour what is that I look cool okay
save station
at times you see it flickering the light
only you can see by a second nature you
reach out and save it thank you guys
look we're doing great
so prime okay well this is very ominous
geez alien nipple it's waving at me
hello alien nipple
good to see you alien nipple look like a
face okay it is a face wait I saw
something moving up there you see it ah
a campaign
Corliss oh that's definitely a face what
is happening here there's something
glowing inside take it
you got the glows hard what in the world
is a glows hard good name
oh geez
okay not on my watch alien nipples I
don't think so
saved you made your body in the light a
power shines within you
breaking through the darkness any pain
you may have I meant on the way for each
people to return okay doing well in this
land only is blinded by darkness can see
the way but it's a puzzle
[Music]
Wow
I must be some kind of genius incredible
he'll do I get anything for activating
that oh hey you saw that Oh again hey
hey back up
come any closer and up Chris
Hugh what don't scare me like that
dumbass unless you want to get clocked
in the face here anyway nf screwing
around
we got to find a way out of here um
right is Harry anyway doesn't matter you
get us into you got us into this match
you get her side how did I do it
I didn't do anything leave the way Chris
look who's a scaredy cat huh oh my god
never mind you walk wait who's loves
alright okay where'd it go who's this
hey Chris there's someone up there
waving at us any idea what they want
sands its sands whoa see right Grayson
Oh God
it's okay I played undertale too I mean
one I know how to do this I'm an expert
I'm channeling all my epic gamer skills
this is a Sara death run everyone I will
die
oh god that was actually close Oh bro
made it Chris down here okay hey whoa
sheesh look at there shoot what I was
like damn
I love they are it's a simple and still
so effective
oh you're not dead sweet got an idea
what the heck this place is meaning them
wonder if there's anyone in that
building out there same station in front
of you a cast aluminum the empty town a
black day sir
emerges from it piercing endlessly to
the sky the pyro this place changed with
a new puzzle what is this a castle why
the hell is there a castle inside a
supply closet
welcome heroes who's there
do not be alarmed I am NOT your enemy
please come forward
Popov you Oh
it sends its gotta be sensible welcome I
am the prince of this kingdom the
kingdom of darkness Chris Susie there is
a legend in this land a legend that one
day two heroes of light will arrive and
propel the ancient prophecy foretold by
Diamond Space Police heroes listen to my
tale listen very well then alright let's
listen to that once upon a time a legend
was whispered among shadows
it was a legend of help it was a legend
of dreams it was a legend of light it
was a legend of dark
this is a legend of delta root delta
rune my god
for millennia light and dark have lived
in balance
breakin Pete this is very Selden
bringing peace to the world but if
there's harmony were to shatter a
terrible calamity would occur
the sky will run black with terror and
the land will crack with pain that
sounds like a bad time then her heart
pounding the earth will draw her final
draft
only then shining with hope three heroes
appear at worlds edge the human a
monster
and a prince from the DA Wow
that fits our description perfectly only
they conceal the fountains the fountains
the geysers
and banish the Angels wrath only then
will balance be restored and the world
saved from destruction
today the fountain of Darkness the
geyser that gives his land pole stands
tall at the centre of the kingdom
that's kind of weird but recently
another fountain has appeared on the
horizon and speaker than a house I don't
like it and with it the balance of light
and dark begins to shift this is this is
interesting I am curious
tell me more Prince of Darkness Chris
Susy thank you for listening to my long
tale
it was very long I'm glad you added that
I deeply believe you two are the terrors
of the legend that despite how whatever
enemies you may face you too had the
courage to save the world
Delta warriors please would you accept
your destiny
well what me some kind of here or
something
you got the wrong person but seriously
without you then the world will so what
if the world gets destroyed it's none of
my damn business might even be kind of
fun honestly anyway Chris if you want to
play pretend with it weirdo stick around
I'm going to find a way out of here
Susy wait what it's and they didn't even
know I was here
my dad's gonna make me so another mad
how many sons does he have let me guess
what who the hell are you the bad
[Music]
you clowns want to see our dog fountain
huh and still picture you guys as clowns
save the world from Eternal Darkness
heart don't try to deny it
we both know your gooey it's your only
way home but I Lancer Lansing won't let
you go there and I've got the flawless
two-step line to ensure it step 1 I
thrash you except you you lose you
thrash you loose hmm nice plan kid
really yeah actually mind if we use it
on you instead oh oh
it's fighting time Chris can act warning
you tell Lazarre to watch out for Suzy's
attack he readies himself
[Music]
park announces bike is fueled by victory
okay boom
don't know how I got an axe but like
that's cool oh yes homeless I love to
get thrashed just kidding Oh God hey
Lance is riding it out did we get him
so what are you guys doing after this no
claims just goin home
oh I'm the bad guy yeah we're Oh what
happens if I go close
hey like charges okay my bag is running
out of fuel all right
you punk a Brewers you had the luck of
draw this time but next time the losers
will be you ha ha ha
bye losers I gotta get home before
dinner you won got 0 XP are you two okay
allow me to introduce myself more
properly
I am jeez can you take off that hood I
can barely hear you under there all
right what hello everyone I'm Ramsay
Chris Suzie it's ever so wonderful to
meet you I am certain we going to become
great friends and best way to leave
these right yes that's where we'll got
it see it's cool Chris I suppose it's
just the two of us then Chris I am your
the Prince of Darkness I am a prince but
I currently don't have any subjects
I've been waiting alone here my whole
life for you to do right so I'm really
happy to meet I hope we can be good
friends Chris let's try to find Suzy she
must be to the southeast you can lead
away Chris
[Music]
well let's just say Rousey the lonely
Prince is now your Alan the power of
fluffy boys shines within you
damn that's one of the strongest powers
this world has ever known
let's keep going why not I'll make this
an extra-long episode what is this Oh
Chris that's the training dummy I mean
now seems like a great chance to prepare
for the enemy would you like me to teach
you at your bite I guess okay get ready
Chris see that hard Chris that's your
soul the culmination of your people
within it holds will your compassion and
the fate of the world
so yeah you probably know undertale you
could choose if you wanted to play a
passive or aggressive I guess that's a
really bad way to put it if you get if
it get hits you and your pencil is hail
everyone then lose HP zero okay obvious
so please take care to avoid enemies
attack ready let's try it okay
[Music]
say it charges if I go close you're a
natural anyhow after the enemy attacks
it's our trip first I'll teach you how
to pipe okay let's try fighting
[Music]
Wow Chris that was an amazing attack
have you done this before or something
okay next let's try defending
oh yeah defending oh I gather TP if I
defend
and now I can spend that TV on spouse
[Music]
now if I use my pacify spelling and will
fall asleep also you can play pacify
the fire
[Music]
acting through this even the most
violent enemies can be defeated through
various acts of kindness if it's leaving
the hood so tell me give it a hug I can
hug around s cube
[Music]
and what is this so weird oh that's
great Chris each enemy has different
acts that satisfy them when an enemy
satisfy its name the yellow when that
happens you can defeat it by spreading
it if we spare all the enemies we meet
we'll never have to fire
[Music]
man what should i do should I spare or
should I fight oh that was fun
you're a wonderful student Chris and in
case you ever need a refresher here I
wrote a menu for you in Susa press C to
open the menu and use it for your yura
in your items
you got the manual you tried to read the
manual but it was so dense and made your
head spin great this is so oh my the
great door is open
no one Ilan said was able to come
through Chris once we pass through this
door our adventure will really begin a
journey for tone exactly by the prophecy
but Chris I believe your choices are
born to this well is full of all kinds
of people Chris in the end how we treat
them makes all the difference so let's
try our best to get by without fighting
if we can manage to do that
I believe this tale may have a happy
otherwise I fear that you may not find
the result favorable oh I'm sorry is
that too much to ask I can handle it
Chris I knew you were here with a moment
SRU let's try our best alright ok so the
game is kind of telling us that we
should try and spare them it seems like
at least that's what I can gather from
this and I remember in on detail the
pacifist was way more fun because they
had like jokes built into them instead
of just killing them so I think we'll
play that right we'll get to I want to
play a love it so pretty look at the
cherry blossoms in this video game ooh
okay enemies ahead you're gonna die sign
law sir
let's play a love anymore
Oh God okay so we have to pacify it
ruling drew near okay so what we do is
we defend defend face my diamond cutter
okay so it charges your TP clearly if
you go closer to it
Brutus glimmering plainly let's defend
and face my diamond cutter okay we
gotcha
[Music]
smells like jewelry now let's act
convinced
does that work Chris wait sorry I messed
up Chris wants to convince and he will
depend you told her into quit fighting
it was utterly sweet yeah I guess I make
sense see what I read
oh that's great this is more fun so now
we get to spare
fruity dislikes it's boss but doesn't
care enough to quit some respect
grace parody you won
oh that's great okay cool
[Music]
so it's fairly simple if you're reading
this I guess you're dead sign Lansing
[Music]
yes of course
yes very what does it say hey don't read
this sign it's a friction practice sorry
I will read it oh if it isn't my two
favorite people site you guys aren't
even in my top five LAN said wait Susie
you mean the Papa girl you fools you're
too late to stop me what did you do
hahaha it was so simple she beat me so I
ran away
that's a bit anti-climatic so are you
just gonna stand there I thought you
would at least run to the right why the
purple girls over there
[Music]
these types of trees don't contain an
item that can heal you whatever you do
don't check the tree and use C to open
your menu
you got it signed lanza there are two
our just hand from the tree take one
yes darka candy
okay
[Music]
should we just hey if your head if you
head that way my troops will trash you
is that a threat I prefer to think of it
as an invitation this game is great I
love it
my necklace of bruton's blocks your path
okay so we'll defend and long live the
guy that replaces shine shine I'm trying
to get close brooding things about
elaborate stones
I can relate I'm just a normal person Oh
[Music]
Ruta dislikes its boss but doesn't care
enough to quit so let's
[Music]
you told reading to quit fighting it was
utterly swayed but the enemy wasn't
tired
oh oh yeah pacify only works if it's
tired so there's different ways to go
about it okay
[Music]
so we can spare brooding and let's try
and defend one more time I forgot what I
need to do don't need to convince again
alright I need to convince again I'm
stupid sorry guys
I missed that okay so act convinced
there you go
it doesn't care enough to quit
[Music]
spare you told ready to confine it was
only swayed okay there we go
I always wait after I did it that's what
happened what is this mom amoeba
I'm Top Chef my latest cake worked me to
exhaustion so I took a little nap but
mom and me but a scary noise woke me up
a piece was hunched on the table eating
the cake like an animal
i spritz it with water and it hissed and
run off but my wonderful cake is Chris
that sounds like sushi we must be going
the right way
let's try to keep her out of any more
trouble mama mama mia mama sheep you
know that feast you please don't come
back the remains of the gegen still
smolder take it sure broken cake all
right why is it burning mama she but I
got I like the fighting systems fun rude
any Haiti block of the way defendant let
me know if I'm doing it right cuz I
don't really know if I'm doing it hey
these body beats audibly
[Music]
okay and then
it worked
[Music]
okay I don't understand
we can spare that one and then we can
[Music]
but it's not tired so this is dependent
Oh God smiles like a soft kiss what does
that smell like
[Music]
okay now we can
now we spam
cute okay that's cool you won
fantastic
check the clock in order to solve this
puzzle y'all have to hurry
[Music]
Wow they're prepared to get lost clown
behold that maze of death prepare to get
lost clowns sign Lancer I think I will
end that episode there I almost I don't
know I want to play more it's so good
how could I not feeling lost yet you
must be utterly helpless
among these twists and turns your sense
of direction won't save you now signed
LAN say it's some sort of enemy it looks
like they got clobbered clobbered what
does that mean
hey wait where am I help somebody help
I'm lost
silence I love it
you open the treasure chest inside the
white ribbon you put white ribbon in
your armor that ribbon is armor crates
it increases defense why don't you try
wearing it in the equipment mini I think
it looked great on you wow what a
supporter
[Music]
what is it
how do I look
that's cool that they out of that hey
don't look this side is private okay
sorry oh it's just this way sign Lancer
hahaha
somehow you survived the mix but don't
count your blessings before they hatch
let's see how you fare against Eckstein
Oh God three of them okay will defend
and
[Music]
look at that hey why aren't you guys
dressed you're totally outnumbered
you made a team the early of support any
Peaks their bullet patterns aren't
balanced at all it's like a dinner made
out of three glasses of milk and that's
an unusual time house why don't we talk
about this after the panel can i spare
already let me try
but the name is in yellow I don't get it
but it seems like it gets yellow even
when from me sparing and spare finally
nope
sweet how much do I get it
you lost Lancer you don't get any oh can
I have some of yours no fine
later night Jesus / rice sap I thought
you were running away damn finished
[Music]
am i doing it wrong
open up your stupid door of great it's
you guys Susie we what a Vassar word
about you um how do you get pants or
spikes before walk through them but this
door sucks
oh don't worry Suzie it will open after
we solve the puzzle over there
nice tell me when you finish it Oh Susie
we need you to finish it
sometimes proceeding will take all three
of it furthermore only crest conceal the
dark pact so if you don't accompany us
you won't make it home
so you're saying I have to stick with
you guys yeah
[Music]
let's get this over with yahoo suit is
back on the team
cue the fanfare Susie Susie follows a
destined such that no one can tell she's
associated oh so say Lake all right so
now I I guess we work the three of us
sounded like a door open all right
what Oh Chris I just realized so she
missed the tutorial next battle we
should show her how to act I think she
might really enjoy that Oh God
Susie do not hurt this creature do not
hurt this adorable creature see Ron
attacked violently you recall right side
of the device
okay so act
[Music]
now let's a pen first
no no what the hell are you doing no no
Hey I stink bye I'm quitting there I'm
not killing that thing okay there's a
savior I'm Suzy I suppose you miss when
I said earlier as heroes we have to okay
all right okay I'll save here and then
I'll eat in the next episode I'll go
back cuz clearly I messed up oh god oh
god oh god no no I thought I had a
different save file I thought I had a
different safehouse
I thought I'd bored oh god oh god